une production du studio sfr
mais aussi en filtrent le podcast on
parle de convaincre nos invités date
site jumelage gratter avec moi
alors que vous nous écoutez présentement
des podcasts s'ils sont disponibles à
nos membres fait tuer on en enregistre
quand même pas mal d'avancé donc vous
avez accès à plein de podcasts vous
abonner notamment louis 6.6 hologue
extraordinaire domino san antonio qui
est une drogue moeurs lâche créatrice de
contenus
incroyable aussi on a un podcast avec
hubert le nord aussi qui est disponible
sur notre page pétrole allait voir ce
c'est la même façon nous encourage et
puis après chaque fois de cas ce qu'ont
fait aussi un petit encore moins de fil
pour son disque décoration de la voir si
c'est exclusif au monde pétri on allait
voir ce set on en donne cette semaine on
parle de masturbation féminine qui seul
sujet la semaine reçoit roxane gaudette
loiseau et mélanie des nets robert
roczen qui est comédienne et mimiques et
sexologue et ils ont écrit ce livre le
petit manifeste mais le monstre de la
masturbation dis-je féminine
quelque chose qu'on ne connaîtra jamais
tout à fait d'accord qu'on peut
connecter au rich man mais l'expérience
ne connaîtra jamais mais c'est pas grave
on voit quand on a des grands novices à
moins que des changements majeurs
qui paient pour ceux qui passaient un
livre ce pas important un livre qui dira
que c'est peut-être l'information sur
tout ce qu'un tout petit quand aux la
masturbation en fait le gros dos féminin
est aussi l'histoire des commandes
cet acte si naturel ici si bénéfique qui
cette saison a été un peu
malmené réprimées dans l'histoire du
sport intéressant c'était super aussi
intéressant de discuter avec tout à fait
de voir aussi l'impact la culture
populaire dans la représentation qu'on
se fait de la masturbation féminine
versus la masturbation masculine aussi
beaucoup plus représenté beaucoup mieux
représentés conversation extrêmement
passionnante juste avant de vous laisser
on va les remercier nos cambistes
le podcast est présenté par idées
cadeaux quebec.com qui est un site qui
regroupe plusieurs entreprises du québec
ou est-ce que vous pouvez aller chercher
des idées cadeaux moi je sais que ont
peu de chance dans ma famille puis à
chaque fois dernière minute de c'est
pourquoi acheter je suis confus puis 1 /
idées cadeaux quebec.com vous pouvez
chercher par prix vous pouvez chercher
par membres de votre entourage avec par
exemple moi j'ai pigé
maintenant le macd doit pas de casque
façon le cerveau mais ce progrès j'ai
peut-être que j'ai quelqu'un d'autre
vous le saurez jamais mais j'ai écrit
son nom sur le site ça me propose des
idées c'est s'enfermer découvrir plein
de compagnies et de produits d'ici donc
en même temps d'encourager des
compagnies québécoises vous en découvrez
le site convivial le site était
conviviale
est extrêmement convivial vraiment
facile à utiliser pour trouver le bon
cadeau rapidement qu'une section de rêve
de santé on se comprend deux c'est
surtout pour semer en fait de sites
existants mais spécialement pour noël
un guide cadeau you le coin pour enfants
et il ya le top 50 des néos by cadeaux
2021 avec la dass et saufs vous allez
trouver ce que vous cherchez pour la
personne
à qui voulait après un cadeau que vous
voulez garder sa queue il peut livrer
directement chez vous ou chez la
personne et vibrer les lignes dans les
fagnes eifel attente et d'intenses ce
tabou a fait savoir qu'il n'ya pas une
nouveauté pour noël pour partir parce
que ça part très rapidement alors à
l'essence est publique et de calais
point com merci beaucoup plus joyeux
temps des fêtes ou même le bac à ces
prétendus par masquer
notre compagnie préférée pour l'homme
masse d'écrits si l'homme moderne est un
homme qui prend soin de lui c'est
vraiment vrai d'avec médical vous avez
tout ce que vous avez besoin pour
prendre soin des idiots lamoureux 4.0 le
bistrot réalité qu'il a de plus le
slameur juste meilleur tennis à la
douche vous raser tout ce qu'ils avaient
arrosé avec sony soins dits du pcf qui
induit times
s'est dit ils vont risquer ma bien moi
j'utilise très régulièrement
pis dans le cac40 il ya plein d'affaires
il ya un cours à wimereux sur un petit
tonneau pour vos parties intimes pour
garder ses frais un déodorant in pas de
bac 3 qui est moindre mais barcelone a
préféré signer plus confortable je les
adore vraiment tout plein d'enfants ph
pièce vous pouvez même avoir les baulois
y vit ici que c'est un fait ça s'appelle
le croate mob ses méthodes dans une
soirée ça se passe bien piloté pas le
temps d'aller prendre une douche tu veux
te rafraîchir un petit peu sous la
saint-urbain chaque image et j'ai adopté
maintenant le sac banane et
6 à mon sac banane toujours prêt avec
moi les croque morts après ce départ un
petit pénis lavabo tennis propre mort
puis un
piteux bref pour la soirée ça et encore
plus sur le site de minsk et vous allez
voir le parfum tout le kit on a un code
promo extraordinaire pour vous qui le
sans fil en un mot c'est 20 % de rabais
avec le shipping gratuit avec noël x en
vient c'est le meilleur cadeau que vous
pouvez vous faire avouer à l'autre
cheikh faye courait sauter là dessus
puis merci mme indiqué que d'encourager
le sans fil du goût
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça tourne merci d'être là c'est
l'éducation
hier j'ai lu votre les félicitations
passant d'entrée de jeu une station pour
ce noble importante peut-être plus ouais
je pense que le premier film qui nous
reçoit
qu'ils aient toutes les balles au crime
si on est content j'ai été captivée puis
ça me fait rire parce que là je viens de
voir par hasard une bougie derrière vous
qui sait marquer american pie parce que
quand je disais votre livre j'ai repensé
à un tweet que j'ai vu passer je me
rappelle plus tu essaies tu est un
humoriste
féministes qui qui a fait ça toute la
qui disait si j'avais de machine à
remonter dans le temps je retournerais
sur le plateau d'american pie ix puis je
leur dirai ont fait patiemment
en lisant les jets j'ai réalisé à quel
point ben la culture populaire entre
autres nous nous donne des images
claires de ce qu'est la masturbation
spécialement la masturbation féminine
pis même inversement la masturbation
masculine puis comment ça a été des
balances et pendant tellement longtemps
pilleurs en lisant votre livre j'ai
vraiment pensé à ça c'est vrai qu'il ya
certaines affaires que je consommais
plus jeunes qui m'ont donné
vraiment bad ce que c'était le jeu magie
n'était en fait il ya tout un chapitre
autour de la culture populaire et autour
de l'histoire de sauna dans le temps
vous autres est ce que ces doux et d'où
est née l'idée première main
de ce livre là et comment ça s'est
manifestée à travers votre
votre véhicule ok ben l'idée est venue
ça fait longtemps que je pense à faire
un livre a créé dans le fond un outil
pour les femmes pour les aider à
découvrir leur corps qui a accédé à
l'orgasme ou à la jouissance mon plaisir
sexuel en général qui bah écoutes je
pense voir 14 ans
sur ses aïeux est acquis c'est quoi
l'orgasme je veux savoir c'est quoi
kechiche flex je me suis rendu compte à
quel point j'étais mal outillés mal
renseigné pour me découvrir tes j'avais
pas point de repère c'est
l'organe sexuel féminin est complexe
c'est juste par le fai qui est interne
ou si du fait qu' on n'en parle pas je
n'ai aucune idée de quoi valeurs qu'ils
toristes entier à l'époque fois que j'y
suis allé à et ces erreurs là vraiment
jusqu'à ce que j'y arrive pas ce que je
dis
[Rires]
pas que c'est premièrement j'ai juste
fait comme ailleurs sérieusement il ya
un manque dans la société niveau
éducation sexuelle je sais pas vous mais
moi mon cours après avoir vu madame
mettre une capote une banane il s'est
rien passé ensemble ça ressemble à un
film je me rappelle avoir appris aussi
que l'intérieur du vagin tu es comme la
même texture l'intérieur d'une bouche
non sérieux mais c'est intéressant quand
vous avez parlé de ça parce que c'est
rare tout le monde les prêts sont en
fait que c'est totalement liste
l'intérieur d'un wagon il ya des
aspérités de scier loi et plis qu'on
appelle transversaux mais il est assez
rare que j'entends déjà corrigé à
celui messier a fait un bon travail
mais étaient bons pour mettre une capote
certains gros pénis en bois
[Rires]
mais c'est ça que j'ai réalisé à ce
moment là que pour vrai il y avait un
gros moment ce niveau là puis un peu
plus tard quand j'ai eu ma fille jette
comme ok là j'ai une responsabilité
concrètes là je veux que ma fille soit
outils et contrairement à moi à l'époque
je veux que ma fille jouissent autant et
si facilement que mon fils il ya quelque
chose là dedans que je trouve c'est une
question d'égalité de genre
l'accès au plaisir et à la jouissance
parce que
il ya des statistiques dont je vais pas
me lancer dans les chiffres je suis pas
mal là dedans mais c'est les femmes ont
beaucoup plus de difficultés à jouir
pendant une relation sexuelle
hétérosexuels moutons
je me dis c'est quoi l'intérêt de se
lancer dans une relation sexuelle quand
même pôle espoir de jouer ou d'en tirer
du plaisir tisser poche rien de fait que
c'est ça c'est vraiment ce que tu es
jumaa petit j'ai fait non je veux qu'un
jeu qu'elle soit autonome sexuellement
je veux que parce que il me semble que
la première étape pour avoir accès à une
sexualité saine qui épanouit c'est
vraiment de connaître son corps puis de
savoir ce qu'on aime parce que c'est
parce que tu aimes comment tu vas le
communiqué après nous hâtons partenaires
je pense que c'est vraiment la base avec
la partie des bleus j'ai vraiment mis en
place ok mise dès de quoi qu'est-ce que
je vais aborder que tout ça est bon j'ai
rejoint les éditions de l'homme n'était
ce pas intéressant cependant l'idée ont
dit ok go vas-y il me manquait un
élément clé l'élément clé ce thème elle
j'avais besoin d'une personne qui avait
le savoir qu'ils possédaient les
connaissances et l'accès aux ressources
aux articles scientifiques pour baky mon
mon essai parce que dans le fond ce que
je vous l'écris c'était vraiment un
outil éducatif chaque niveau crédibilité
je voulais que ce soit béton je voulais
pas juste que ça soit quelque chose sûre
c'est
mon expérience n'est pas du tout le
reste est parce que c'est là que
militari dans le projet de mennonites et
des sexologues oui exactement et puis
j'ai ma forme n'est pas tout sur qu'est
ce que tu disais par rapport à la
culture un peu plat parce que je trouve
ça super intéressant parce que c'était
une des visées nucléaires est d'aider
les gens à avoir un regard critique sur
dans quelle société on évolue comment ça
forge notre sexualité puis on sait que
la connaissance les connaissances et le
pouvoir fait qu'un char mesure de
réfléchir de positionner des questionnés
mais c'est sûr que je reprends de
pouvoir sur ma sexualité c'est ce qu'on
voulait faire par rapport à la
masturbation féminine fait que jouer que
l'exemple que te donner c'était parfait
quand on regarde
1 c'était vraiment pas la même chose
qu'aujourd'hui non on en parle davantage
maintenant la masturbation chez les
femmes mais encore ça reste limitée puis
si on retourne une dizaine d'années il y
avait pratiquement rien c'était beaucoup
d images qui était problématique
justement les femmes étaient très
invisibilité la place qu'elle avait dans
les films outils la masturbation ce
texte marque présentée comme frustration
sexuelle n'est pas capable d'avoir un ou
une partenaire fait que c'est votre
masturber et y avait quelque chose de
ridicule c'est une femme devenait comme
accro à rester seules
les grosses images vraiment heureux le
top 6 du du gros bras
oui une abstention
il est jeune fille ou la nouvelle
génération a pris en trois points homme
en vie le
tibet non non idéal mal c'est vraiment
sauter puis non seulement on voulait que
ce soit un outil éducatif
mais d'où le titre du petit manifeste
nous important pour nous aussi que les
jeunes filles et les femmes qui le
lisent
comprennent d'où vient le malaise a
touché leur corps d'où vient leur
insécurité là c'est jeudi on a vraiment
pris une position féministe dans
l'écriture livre est ici pour se situe
parlais tantôt du chapitre plutôt
historiquement pour parler de la
sexualité des femmes à travers
l'histoire puis la masturbation
traversons c'était pu constater la
baisse est vraiment frappante c'est
juste à chaque fois que vous faites
référence mettant un terme d'utiliser
qui tire de son de lui qui aime tant
qu'ils
découvriront de fallope qui vient de
l'italien le valais fario à la plus haut
placée comme les trompes de fallope ça
s'appelle fallope à cause que c'est un
homme qu'ils auraient découvert noyé
camille pin y en a beaucoup la pelouse
d'agen comme sogeti permet en fait c'est
qu'on propose nous fait des baskets
c'est comme si les hommes devaient
conquérir l'accord des phares sur peau
couleur locale ration spatiale du web
j'ai mal aux pieds en fait c'est juste
que ces personnes là ont fait une
description les organes génitaux
féminins souvent souvent failli
tourner à une certaine époque de leur
point de vue les corps des femmes ou des
personnes qui ont une vulve été soit
représenté un référent en comparaison
aux corps des hommes ben on explique le
corps des hommes comme ça fait qu'on va
partir de là pour expliquer le corps des
femmes etc c'est vrai que c'était pas
nécessairement je sais qu'on peut e qui
connaît mieux le corps des femmes âgées
les femmes elles-mêmes se prend pour
donner son nom à une marque
de trouver les trompes de fallope tracé
car ils pensent à fait patent c'est pour
ça aussi on propose des alternatives à
dire les trompes utérine l irlande par
ailleurs être allé au lieu des glandes
de skene c'est dans le vocabulaire on
pense que l'on peut se réapproprier
notre corps notre sexualité et si moussa
j'avais entendu aussi qu'elle le quitte
et rice avait été vraiment comme
écartées comme les livres de biologie
puis malté des études parce que c'était
comme considéré comme un organe du
sydney ouais mais en fait à partir du
moment où parce que bon il ya eu
plusieurs théories comme quoi la semence
des femmes étaient produites au moment
de l'orgasme féminin à ce moment l'on
pensait que bon avec les deux semences
ont créé la vie à partir du moment où ça
n'a pas eu de fonctions reproductives
qu'on a découvert que non il n'y avait
pas de semences qui étaient déclenchées
par l'orgasme féminin on s'est mis à
dire que c'était totalement inutile et
c'est même devenu une menace parce que
c'était le plaisir pour le plaisir chez
la femme c'est évidemment ça toujours
fait
visiblement très parrot à ces messieurs
alors il ya eu une réaction en anglais
non vous autres l'égoïsme à l'époque tu
es c'est devenu vraiment l ennemi à
abattre douze justement on a vu le fait
que après le clitoris avec tu es
vraiment occulté de toutes les planches
anatomiques
c'est hallucinant c'est vraiment un
contrôle de la femme par le contrôle de
sa sexualité mythes sont encore on en
est venu à eau m volontairement un
organe complet c'est hallucinant
c'est quoi les dangers d'une femme qui
jouissait nos sens que pour quoique
qu'on a voulu tard réprimer ces mets ton
cas qu'on regarde même j'ai panda dans
l'ailé dans la religion d'exercer depuis
des millénaires quatre ans qu'on veut
réprimer le plaisir féminin ex aequo la
menace qu est ce que je comprends pas
tu me permets aussi je pense que
l'orgasme la jouissance c'est pas la
menace c'est juste que ce c'est comme
une conséquence du fait que la femme a
pris la liberté de se découvrir c'est
l'autonomie qui fait peur aux hommes
c'est le fait que la femme soit à gentil
fica décide d'explorer son corps de
jouir sans l'homme en plus
c'est la clique contrôlant c'est de
garder l'autre dépendantes soit quand
l'autre s'affranchit c'est plus
difficile après de le contrôler je pense
que c'est une des pistes clairement et
qui explique pourquoi ça semble avoir
fait pas si longtemps on a dit aussi
qu'une femme qui lit et dangereuse est
une femme qui se dit qu'on apprend c'est
une femme qui développe son esprit
critique
si moi je sais très bien faire jouer
j'ai du plaisir j'arrive avec toi jean
nipon je vais peut-être que flash est
facilement si je sais que ton
comportement est inapproprié ou que je
suis victime d'abus mais je te quitter
plus tôt que reste avec toi
je pense qu'il sait c'est quand même fou
de voir sud sous cet angle le ticket le
tri lacunes qu'on a au niveau des
connaissances sur l'orgasme féminin sur
l'année de menacer si le fruit de siècle
de contrôle ah ouais de conditionnement
c'est ça dépend de la science de
l'époque passé sont cités comme temps
tout dépend maintenant avant que j'ai
vraiment une présentation claire de
complexes qui tord où il retrouva gines
absurde et quand il revenait son
reviendra
mais en fait c'est tout dépendant
l'époque il ya des moments où est ce que
les six étaient des femmes ont été plus
célébrés effet en trop dans l'antiquité
mais il ya des moments où est-ce que ça
a été occultée ça dépend des thés
l'église a eu de contrôle la famille
l'haïtien la séance il a tissé par
moments ça dans le fond on avait des
connaissances
après ça les connaissances on les
cachait apprécié un urologue hélène aux
consoles qui est vraiment content qui
nous a aidés à mieux comprendre ces
coire se complique le complexe littoraux
une retrouvaille finale puis elle a fait
perçu que il dans le fond il ya des
dessins qui ont été omis comme s'il est
entouré cinq volontaires menti des
planches anatomiques
autant dans les années 80 c'est les
schémas par rapport au pénis donné plus
complexe plus complète un montant au
niveau du clitoris bas on présentait
glandus qui t'arrive mais on oublie
beaucoup de sections dis donc elle a dit
c'est de faire de mener des recherches
sur des entractes des sections des irm
pis pour qu'on comprenne mieux en quoi
ça consiste ce complexe l'appui ce que
si jamais il ya des gens qui sont
intéressés on en parle de cette
pionnière lé dans le livre qu'elle a
vraiment permis aux gens de davantage à
prendre sur les kiters fax aussi ça fait
quelques décennies qu'on compte vraiment
qu'on connaît a admis comme il faut
certes pas longtemps mais les premières
descriptions interne guitariste et un
lieu plus parler 16ème siècle comme et
et oui ça fait longtemps qu'on les suit
on a tous l'impression que c'est nouveau
et ça fait longtemps que dans le fond
les lits les institutions patriarcale
l'ont découvert
c'est juste que comme elle dit ça a été
complètement flashy pts et les moments
où
on ne valorise et l'orgasme féminin
comme elle disait tonton c'était
vraiment ça coïncide vraiment avec une
époque où l'on croyait que c'était utile
à la reproduction
ces stocks par haïti mais même en fait
le moyen âge ça l'est vraiment été
période de merde
pour globalement le dit dans le fond
parce que dans votre vie vous expliquer
justement l'antiquité puis comment
c'était déjà
comment on était au courant que la femme
pouvait jouer depuis que c'était aussi
je pense importante
parallèlement six passion puis vraiment
le moyen âge a été une période de merde
pour tout le type la religion a joué de
nombreux rôles lada sans aucun doute le
mais ces fous pareils que pendant aussi
longtemps à 10 par an si on dirait que
c'est même si
fins 16ème siècle qu'on parlait pour la
la la je ne fais pas la pression mais la
représentation
mais reste maintenant la la masturbation
féminine dans les vous l'expliquer que
c'est vraiment avec la révolution
sexuelle des années 70 ce que c'est que
ces revenus sur sur la carte comme étant
quelque chose de positif qu'ils m'ont
intimé c'est fou le pareil ça et c'est
long mais le pays et le sait que même
pendant la révolution sexuelle on s'est
rendu compte que la masturbation
particulièrement féminine a été la
grande oubliée dans les pratiques
sexuelles ce qui a été l'immense passion
sexuelle des femmes et des hommes mais
des femmes oui mais la masturbation on
en aura autant parler c'est cette espèce
de l'impression qu'on a eu que c'est
pourtant une pratique sexuelle valable
ou valais dans soi qu'il faut mines et
c'est pas une pratique à défaut de à
défaut d'avoir un partenaire à défaut
d'avoir les capacités sociales à
connecter avec quelqu'un pas du tout tu
peux être en coupe pratiquer la
masturbation c'est super satisfaisant
c'est complémentaire registre et fait
que
le négligé ou un petit plus des années
80 était quand même beaucoup d'un
regroupement des femmes féministes en
sortent des livres sur la sexualité des
femmes parce qu'il se rendait compte que
ce qu'ils voyaient dans la littérature
c'était pas aussi riches que leurs
propres observations les années 80 et
commence à avoir plus de documentation
écrite par des femmes pour des femmes
qui était même là on voit aussi j'aime
trop qu'on en parle de schirrhein qui
est fait noël qui nous a vraiment permis
d'apprendre sa sexualité des femmes mais
elle a reçu des messages tellement et
nous ça a tellement cheap en font chacun
pour les gens qu'elle ait fini par voter
pour les hommes voient fortement oui
effectivement volé c'est
vraiment ma fille est en fait elle a
même renoncé à sa citoyenneté américaine
pour reprendre ces sujets
on voit quelques boissons
à faire
on parle on parle tantôt irak sans
qu'ils aient par rapport à que tu es
toullec ta petite fille jouait ce autant
et aussi facilement que ton petit gueule
moi je pense qu'il y aura vraiment
quelque chose d'eux parlant sur notre
premier rapport à la sexualité parce que
moi maintenant cette conversation
l'homme âgé de 30 ans cette conversation
là je n'ai jamais eue avec personne avec
mes parents jamais le saint-james était
quelque chose qui était misrata même que
c'était quelque chose que je disais pas
que je faisais cet écrit que j'ai appris
vraiment moi même tout seul avec
évidemment en tant qu'homme des schémas
vraiment plus tôt et puis plus facile à
comprendre que si j'avais été une femme
sauf que reste que cette idée là de
masturbation était qu'elle était pour
quasiment étaient négatives dans notre
salon qui se passe bien oui puis
je pense que cette attitude là de dire
mettant à mal jouer j'aimerais ça que
mes enfants puissent découvrir leur
corps mais mais mais enfin go films et
principalement mais ma petite fille
puisse découvrir son corps dans un
contexte qui est cinq puits positif
ça doit passer par là au début le tice
j'imagine les jeunes que c'est pour la
première le premier contact texte doit
être positif sinon ça reste longtemps un
espèce de catherine séguin quand on
parlait d'un truc fanta abordé qu'il y
avait un accord orgasmique des fois tu
dans des couples hétérosexuels admettons
mais on le voit aussi que
malheureusement c'est chez les filles on
par les jeunes filles souvent la
masturbation vaut venir après une
première relation sexuelle avec
winch et les ja chacun s'est souvent
linverse la maturation vierge à
l'aller dans le fond le malaise la gêne
que tu que tu ne mets on la retrouve
encore plus chez les jeunes filles
d'aujourd'hui comme si c'était pas
possible de pouvoir prendre plaisir à
son propre corps comme s'il fallait que
nécessairement mon plaisir soit tourné
vers l'autre puis que ce soit l'autre
qui me garantissent montplaisir fake je
pense que c'est effectivement énormément
important d'avoir une éducation sexuelle
qui positive et ouverte parce qu'elle
amasse au basson on n'a pas suffisamment
c'est la raison pour laquelle qui
justement que la masturbation chez les
jeunes filles et des fois inexistante
parce que c'est parce qu'ils savent
juste pas que ça existe que c'est
possible parce que il ya une honte
rattache à ce sujet parce que c'est quoi
la moi à l'époque le la masturbation
pour une femme le j'étais quasiment pas
au courant que ça se pouvait temps
j'étais vraiment pas clair que c'était
une pratique en soi mais je pense que ça
c'est de mieux en mieux au locle armes
mais été utilisé il ya quand même un
processus pour
mettre faut mettre les bâtiments avec
des enfants pour qu'ils soient à l'aise
avec sotigui autant chez les garçons que
celle effectivement mon garçon et si
c'est quoi
démonstration il comprend le cycle
menstruel probablement mieux que bien
des oeuvres malheureusement il se sait
quoi clitoris ma petite fille aux cinq
ans ça fait longtemps que c'est quoi
mais pour réel le clitoris et le glaçon
qui théorise pas ce que l'on a besoin
pour l'instant comprendre toute la pâte
mais c'est pas blanc latour sobrement
complexe
c'est pertinent aussi tous ceux qui sont
à l'école qui veulent faire une certaine
sion qui manque de bol
mais c'est tellement d'accord avec toi
rex parce que ces importantes et jeux
sont on le sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
jeunes filles ou même des points portent
les gens il ya beaucoup de personnes qui
ont pas les mots pour nommer leur corps
comme pas les connaissances pour drogba
oui il ya beaucoup de femmes entre
autres des poneys refermant juste des
jeunes qui savent pas ce que les cinq
sont enclavés levé le vagin qui vont
utiliser le mot vagin pour parler de la
vulve c'est déjà juste d'avoir des
connaissances de savoir comment mon
corps et faire on intimide pas avoir de
mal à l'aise et on dit que c'est tout un
bond à prendre nos enfants les vrais
terme pour pas qu'ils déconnent une
connotation négative émotif qui qui est
chargée qui reliait tout comme s'ils
étaient cachés où je devais en parler en
chantant le c'est ce qu'on essaie
d'éviter puis
on est toutes les deux très convaincu
que tout passe par l'éducation en fait
la toute forme de barbarie parce que tu
disais tantôt que
bon à l'époque au moyen âge c'était
vraiment une époque
chitti mais honnêtement le on est quand
même encore dans une époque de marde on
a donné beaucoup puis on est aussi parce
qu on est super privilégie des fois on
oublie parce que encore tous les jours
il ya des milliers d'excision du culte
au risque qui se font sur des bébés
naissant des jeunes filles je vais ya
encore un monde
dans un monde où on nous annonce encore
des féminicides quotidiennement
c'est ça peut pas être inutile de de
redonner
puis d'encourager les jeunes filles à
être gentil via s'approprier leur corps
c'est pour ça oui
j'avais
dit non mais non mais non
[Musique]
commencés qui est est cette terre lui
finalement il termine
et on a peut-être même l'impression que
enzo scifo studios ont produit un
podcast qui s'appelle sexe oral qui est
oui il en adopte jo annie grenier puis
c'est moi dans le dernier jeu pendant la
dernière année là dernier deux ans où
est ce que j'ai vu un peu leur bain
j'écoutais leur peau car j'ai vu comme
l'attraction que ce podcast là avec
l'intérêt que les gens avaient discuté à
entendre deux femmes discuter de leur
plaisir
elle initie mais c'est exact et puis en
plus le faire de l'effet en fait ils
font vraiment bien de façon vraiment
c'est super décomplexée puis vraiment
positive le jpy
puis démocratise plusieurs pratiques
notamment la
découverte du sexe féminin puis il ya
tellement un intérêt frappant pour ce
mois je me jette à terre à quel point le
monde sont intéressés par quels sont les
femmes ils se sentent interpellés par ce
podcast le puis je me dis criminal ben
arfa c'était absolument nécessaire la
tradition ouais ce qui est cool c'est
que en fait
moi je pense que justement par rapport à
ceux et celles qui sont dupes a
interpellé comme départ des podcasts
comme ça c'est en plus ses fils et
partagent leurs expériences qu'ont vécu
leur ressenti et il leur sentiment par
rapport à tout ce je pense que le lait
vient à être un bon complément parce que
ceux-ci ce qui vient valider ton
ressenti plus scientifiquement sont
votés ouais c'était génial plus on va en
avoir de son mieux ça va
il ya des témoignages aussi justement
dans livre on a des femmes de différents
âges et des différentes origines et on
est des femmes de différents horizons
qui ont prêté leur voix tu es dans
l'ivresse que ça aussi ça peut être
puissant de sentir de se reconnaître à
travers l'autre et de son tour validé
aussi dans notre expérience et l'otan
par le podcast qui elles par des
témoignages on a eu des femmes
incroyables qui nous ont fait des petits
bijoux de témoignages est ce que tient
avec la avec le confinement le comme les
le marché des objets sexuels
exploser complètement le thé nous on a
un partenaire qui est un magasin qui
s'appellerait ces compagnies puis les
autres c'est le tout petit loup depuis
principalement des trucs pour bien pour
les fameux tee puis est-ce que balaie ce
que les dernières années ont ont eu lé
est-ce que les dernières années ont été
aussi progressiste que je jeu que je les
ressens tu y mets ton par rapport à la
masturbation féminine par rapport à la
réappropriation de la sexualité de la
femme ou ses jeux c'est juste parce que
c'est plaisant mais je pense que c'est
juste un feeling que tout ne serait ce
que dans la diversité des objets sexuels
dans la recherche qui a été fêtée on
retourne maintenant c'est comme bien
normal mardi avant août avait tu avais
parce que pour les objets sexuels pour
les femmes c'était vraiment
représentation phallique c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui était dans la
pénétration c'est un objet pénètre alors
que maintenant tu as des idées vraiment
d'aider des objets des objets sexuels
qui stimule le gland du clitoris des
objets instruction n'est donc je pense
que oui ça dénote clairement le fait que
ok les femmes comprennent maintenant que
joueur ça se peut que ça vienne pas
parler après une pénétration réel
puis ses rêves québec mais aussi je
pense que une évolution est plus de
représentation des dents actuellement
dans les films les séries commencent à
aborder les représentations est dans le
milieu de la chanson ou fit je pense
entre autre nicki minaj mon âme ses
tickets mairie est ce que on a le tec
l'impression que or on en parle partout
maintenant mais on le dit en tout cas on
est quand même plus légers pis si vous
êtes des gourmands
partout maintenant qui admettons je
pense est moi je regarde les pages
instagram que les compte instagram que
je suis c'est sûr que j'en vois plus
suite des choses pour lesquelles j'ai
des intérêts je pense qu'il ya encore
beaucoup de gens pour qui le malaise est
présent dans l'éducation et pas
nécessairement pour ses vins cusiter
mais c'est sûr qu'il ya une évolution
qui est ce que je tourne ce qu'on avait
vu dans les recherches aussi c'est qu'il
ya une augmentation au niveau de
l'argent frais pour des ventes de haut
niveau des marchés du marché des jouets
sexuels puis les prévisions vont en
augmentation et est ce que ça veut dire
que les gens on sait que ça a été plus
positive c on ne sait pas dans le sens
que je pense que c'est pour une somme on
y pense on me sort mais aussi mais on
sait pas est ce que les jantes et ceux
qui souhaitent vivre mais pour moi tout
que juste le fait que les gens aillent
je pense aussi que les objets sexuels
puis jouets sexuels sont plus être
excessivement aujourd'hui amazon
fr
je pense que ça aide à démocratiser
et à susciter curiosité sans trop se
montrer que
c'est vraiment plus accessible que je
pense que oui je pense que c'est quand
même moi j'y vois un bon signe en tout
cas le fait que les ventes augmentent
piquer les femmes etc des nouvelles
choses parce que sasuke quand même un
désir de ce explorer la
course lorsque ceci dit quand même
quelque chose qui n osent pas ce qu'il
sait c'est sûr que le fait que ça soit
plus privé plus plus discret justement
ça encourage parlant beaucoup de monde à
en acheter pas découvrir ce mais ça
montre encore que c'est quelque chose
quand tu as caché qu'un malaise qu'il
faut comme pour tant que ça paraisse
possible le plus discret possible de
mieux s'alimenter pitié quelque chose
d'important ne parlait du confinement
mais il ya une application logique oui
j'ai oublié le nom les pièces hamon en
parlant livres pieds c'est clube
sexuelle je me suis dit oui qui en fait
une application web store les gens qui
se masturbe en même temps que toi c'est
ce talent pas de convois légère mais
pratiquement non moins 4 ou l'autre
c'est vraiment bien c'est une à
pierrefonds qui est incluse et tu mets
le genre que pour l'égal du banc le fait
d'identifier qui est appréciable tu peux
m t'as pas besoin de mettre ton adresse
exacte mais ça m'est apparu hâtivement
ci s'effectuera permet aussi de
démocratiser la masturbation puis de
voir que bunge postulent à pratiquer la
masturbation effectifs ça peut être
intéressant on avait tombé là dessus
pendant notre chien je pense pas que les
gars aient besoin de temps d'être
assurés que leurs voisins se masturber
en même temps que pour une femme à part
tellement de loin que puis encore
tellement comme de culpabilité puis
devant là est ce que ça peut être quand
même un incitatif à foix comme au hockey
je peux peut-être maintenant et profiter
de mon petit moment c'est fou quand même
qui fait que l'application dans le fond
c'est ça ça rassure toi là dessus puis
ça permet de voir un peu à quel point
finalement c'est tout tiré par un
métier tu m'aimes
en fait la question est pourquoi est-ce
que tu pars tu parlais de la culpabilité
le tipi des disputes et même mois mais
dont le jeu je me fais vieux tu me fais
venir un masturbateur chez nous le
mettons
juin je préférerais qu'ils respectent ce
rapport
je vois pas le mettre à table
chevènement et pourquoi il ya pourquoi
on ne sait pas ce que c'est finalement
dans une société grecque tout le monde
se masturber mais tu as raison c'est
selon moi la star besoins essentiels se
met à mon sens
mais on met ça ça vient avec l'histoire
on nous a tellement dit que c'est pas
bon vous allez rendre malade que tel à
leur faire puisque le synthé porté par
le silence de tes parents aussi par
profitait pas aborder ce si on doit leur
âge et pas de partenaire de ce c'est
quelque chose qui était pas aussi vaincu
les étés c'est comme un looser moyer
des messages qui sont véhiculés qu'ils
sont erronés s'il ya une partie qui
ressuscite c'est ton intimité c'est
correct mais pourquoi on a autant
d'inconfort pris de malaises mais ces
questions est ce que est ce que mes
torts que c'en est une
est une anomalie mais ton avec son
ouverture avec ses enfants ou maintenant
les jeunes parents mettons ces c'est
vraiment plus ouvert qui mettons dans
notre temps un tir parce que mettons
justement mes parents il y avait avait
quand même hein quand même on
n'entendait pas lundi puis ces
générations le pi maintenant est ce que
ça a changé mais ton chez les nouveaux
parents ont su prouver par contre si tu
me permets il ya peut-être plus d'outils
d'éducation à la sexualité de disponible
puis c est ce que les parents sont moins
sont plus confortables 10h pour et
politique par rapport à ça m'était entre
autres ça peut aider maintenant à
l'école c'est vrai que les contenus
pédagogiques en éducation à la sexualité
on doit entre autres abordé le plaisir
sexuel tiff avec des fois ça peut être
un levier aussi pour le parent et il ya
dans ça dépend des milieux et il ya
aussi dans les centres de services
scolaires c'est des porteuses de doucier
du porteur de dossier des sexologues et
je pense peut-être qu'au niveau des
outils ya une accessibilité qui est
différente mais tu pourrais pas dire est
que les parents sont plus cons je pense
que ça s'améliore lentement trop
lentement goût mettewie champs comme un
malaise là c'est ma petite
bio comme deux ans était était au cpe
puis
on est allé faire son pipi toilettes peu
la leçon éducatrice se demandait si
c'était correct a dit oui je suis mot
pictoris
agadir qui te fait qu'elle suit sont
pitot restée le premier réflexe de
l'éducatrice ça a été quand j'étais chez
ma fille dams et
qui sait pas comment ce qui
m'a pas dit ou fait on n'a pas brisé
mais elle était quand même vraiment
comme est donné oui déstabiliser de même
chose pour mon fils qui a fait des
commentaires en cause pour expliquer le
cycle menstruel
à peu près à l'âge de 4 ans tee
lemonnier est vraiment parfois choquer
même je t'aiderai fait oui je pense que
je tombe une bibitte encore
si je pense que c'est une personne très
ouverte bon mon
ma vision aussi de la nudité
avec les enfants par rapport aux enfants
petit jeu là c'est encore différent tu
encore un regard différent pilloud 8 et
des foyers
youtube c'est ce que je me suis même de
la réaction du papa de mes enfants car
mon fils avait à peu près trois ans
quand il a vu que j'avais du sang fait
que j'étais monstre 8 minimum dont les
mamans pourquoi tu sais ce que tu as mal
que tu es blessé
j'ai vulgariser pour qu'ils comprennent
dans ses mots à lui sauf que je lui ai
expliqué qu est ce qui se passait
concrètement pis je me souviens que son
parti était ce vraiment nécessaire
d'expliquer qu'elle est un nid dans ton
ventre qui défait tous les mois pour
accueillir un oeuf f qui est fécondée
par une graine globe dans ses testicules
qui passe par le peniste moral est là
mais au bout du compte mon fils ne fait
au brun camp de san mamés y comprenne
comment on fait des enfants comme on
peut se reproduire ils comprennent aussi
pourquoi ben tel ami dans la classe deux
mamans ils comprennent pourquoi est-elle
enfants pas nécessairement la couleur de
peau qui est elle et puis je pense que
plus grands pas mais on va faire des
êtres humains est
bon est ouverte et le tabou pile malaise
la cie peau il peut y il construit notre
site on a faim de cinq ans pour lui
c'est que tu parles du palais des nuages
comment ça fonctionne plus
c'est ainsi que l'on retrouve la même
affaire d accès aux quais si tu décides
qui est malade puis
il a exactement sa première un plus
souvent c'est que ces curiosités l'oeil
ils ont tous nés avec le ticket quand tu
découvres des sensations qui commence à
expérimenter plus tu te fais dire non
oui espérons le c'est pas normal et
naturel
en fait même un bébé le très jeune
stimulent leurs organes génitaux c'est
pas normal je peux leur dire ma chérie
mon chéri tu veux faso par exemple
emprunt moment pour toi il faut pas que
c'est je pense que c'est vraiment de
sermonner
pour plutôt leur expliquer concert de
l'intimité comme je suis né qui la
consomme ainsi signé de ma plume est
plutôt oui comprennent tout seul et
multi mois ci c'est une évidence ou
quelque chose qui comme acquis des puits
ont un comblement acquis de communes
pour le tc sur la sexualité va de pair
avec consentement si on
gagne quand même un bon garde avant ce
moment
mon neveu sont fait installer un bidet
chez eux puis il restait dix minutes
subi des
viols voyez quelque chose le type le
secam foxy le travail de d'expliquer oui
c'est quoi en même temps a dit ben badi
minutes subi des six lots pas mal mais
je n'y voyais canada tu sais pas trop
quoi
c'est encore un espèce de ta boule à la
stimulation en ald
le sexe anal tous et encore gaspard
tabou puis il ya encore un espèce de
de préjugés puis de hugo m ait dissimulé
un allemand hop on discute de son
orientation sexuelle tatata coach je
trouve que l'on devrait tellement
l'institut derrière le du plaisir c'est
du plaisir le temps que ça reste dans ta
adultes consentants le d'où ça vient
brosses à
dents sont les tabous en tirant trois
les pratiques anales parce quelqu'un on
ne fait les recherches on en parle
justement nous oui de la nuit 5 rocks
dans les livres puis de plaisir qu'une
femme pour orienter ses pendants la
masturbation mais quand on faisait des
recherches et avait tellement pas de
chaussures lui sinon par yooz des vulves
ou du vagin mais rien entourant la zone
anale fêter ce théâtre est limité fait
quand je pense que c'est ce que tu as
encore le seul guillou qui peuvent
retrouver les références le sait la
pornographie traditionnels puis quand et
tantôt c'est pas la représentation qu'on
n'a vraiment pas bien fait qu avez-vous
découvert quelque chose sur le sujet où
est la fonte sur le sujet du plaisir
anal ou bien vu qu'on connaît rien on
est encore en train car à ce niveau là
mais ton qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est ce qu'on
sait qu'ils sont plaisir mais la nervure
et l'anus seront pas très beau couple
aisé je pense aussi la pénétration anale
pour un homme ça vient stimuler la
prostate qui est une zone érogène son
souci mais pour ce qui est des hommes on
n'a pas creusé
par rapport à la main sur bastion mais
on parle seulement de différents types
de jouets sexuels une qu'elles peuvent
être utilisés par pour ce type de
pratique là on parle aussi du fait que
si pas tout le monde qui apprécient la
pénétration anale mettez le pourtour
peut être simulé pieds carrés avec les
doigts at on donne on va en fait on
parle des diverses pratiques que les
femmes auxquelles peuvent avoir recours
les outils collectifs donc c'est ce
qu'on parle un peu de je pense était
d'enlever le tabou aussi quand on sait
déjà que c'est la masturbation chez les
femmes c'est peut-être plus taboue mais
c'est la masturbation qui implique la
région anale ça l'est d'autant plus avec
eux on voulait dans le fond normalisé
valdes et les femmes pour qui c'est leur
expert c'est plaisant
jeu
j'ai eu un cours à l'université qui
était sexualité cinéma qui dans le court
à ce moment là dans ma vie je t'ai pas
nécessairement prêts à aborder projeté
pas près j'aurais dû light mais c'était
vraiment un choc l'interprétation qu'on
avait eue d'une syncope en particulier
je me rappelle plus c'est quoi le film
sauf que notre professeur avait dit
c'était un film réalisé par une auteure
féministe c'est un film de de
pornographie avait rico siffredi là
dedans qui comme le point histoire
italien qui faisait qu'il fait en un
cross vers le cinéma c'est vraiment un
film
c'est de la pornographie mais avec avec
une histoire justice et de la neige dans
un film de genre ouais c'est ça mais
comme avec les cinq vraiment clair de
pornographie puits afin dalphond là le
film finissait sur un close up du vagin
avec la tête d'un bébé qui sortent et
puis notre professeur avait dit ceci
c'est la
représentation du
du beauty shot tactile comme shot afin
des films pornos l'estrie a pris cette
image là pour mettre une image encore
plus forte que c'est la femme qui au
final olé le dernier mot surtout le
trident dans cette histoire le projet
fait
je suis choquée de ce qu'elle venait de
voir
toutes les le concept puis dans votre
livre vous parlez de
une des raisons pourquoi l'éjaculation
féminine était temps si souvent c'est
parce que l'homme voyelles espèce de
mouvement de puissance de l'éjaculation
masculine qui se sentait attaquée par la
reprise de 2 cl femmes en travail
puissant encore plus puissant
trouve ça fascinant comme comme bien et
puis j'ai fait ce lien avec ma tête de
finalement le film que j'avais regardé
au final c'était quand même vraiment
avant gardiste de retourner les codes
absolument que le fameux poste finissent
sur un comme choc 10 finissent sur
l'ultime comme choc dans le forez
si la pornographie féministe fait
beaucoup ont accès dans la pornographie
plus mainstream plus traditionnelle
c'est toujours c'est majoritairement
l'éjaculation masculine qui faisait dans
le fond la fin des jours scénario
pour la fellation sous l'appellation
masculine qui commence puis
l'éjaculation en
qui on appelle seul le money shot
souvent mais au niveau de
l'apprentissage et les choses
finissent on voit que l'éjaculation chez
les fang chez les personnes qui ont une
vulve et souvent dans le fond ce qui met
fin à tout scénario tu es comme
justement décapité le revirement des
gens
l'élargissement
cdi be called mais on le retrouve cela
dans la pornographie féminine justement
l'éjaculation féminine qu'ils avaient
échappé de la suisse dans le livre pis
moi c'est quelque chose que je ferai
voter vous dit il souvent peu de
documentation peu de données je devais
voulu faire mes propres recherches a tué
à savoir d'où ça venait qu'est ce que
c'était petit ce puissant trouver
tendinite et oui nous autres si on avez
vous des réponses à mes questions mais
plus il il envoyé on va voir si on a des
réponses c'est probablement contents ne
peut être mal choisi ses côtés question
c'est y mais on sait tout du service
affaires le doute c'est quoi c'est quoi
la classe féminine mais tente encore si
claire de où ça vient ça dépend aussi de
quel type déjà qu l'on parle on en
connaît 3 les exposés mels baisse et ça
en fait et encore le même en 2021 les
auteurs les autres ils sont consentantes
pour toutes mes disques et nous on ne
trouvait plus intéressant pour notre
livre des deux auteurs avec pastor et
chemine je sais pas
ils en ont oui on comme ils se sont
vraiment attardé à la question puis on
fait une énorme recension puis c'est
entre autres ce qu'ils disent est et
qu'il pourrait y avoir un oeil
distinguer trois phénomènes
principalement l'éjaculation féminine où
on pourrait durer jacques ulation
vulvert parce que toute personne qui a
une vue levée à cette possibilité là où
la majeure des bips les personnes qui
ont une vulve puis en fait il ya une
partie qui proviendraient en fait quand
aux cantons a glissé un mot sur le
complexe qui luttent au rohu rétro
vaginale tout le monde donc pas ce
qu'est ce qu'on voit ce qui est le plus
présent pas est-ce qu'on voit d'emblée
c'est le gland du clitoris mais on sait
que le neuf dixièmes du clitoris est
interne comme l'iceberg
une image qui en fait dans le font qu'un
ainsi par exemple si je stimule le
premier tiers du vagin mais ça stimule
en même temps le clitoris dans sa partie
interne c'est comme si le clitoris
chevauche un peu comme une cavalière
dans un corbeau une call girl est il
chevauche les dans le fond le vagin pis
l'urètre fake cij stimule le premier
parlement vagin mais ça stimule aussi
mon clitoris et fastidieux luz en même
temps le petit gland dur glandulaires de
lure est ce que ça fait c'est que
certaines femmes avec ce type de
stimulation le haut certaines personnes
qu'une ville pourrait connaître une
éjaculation parce qu'on appelle les
glandes parlera urétral donc c'est des
glandes et de soyaux des petits orifices
loup lui respire et un liquide ce qui
serait se crée t mais là quand par
l'éjaculation féminine selon ses auteurs
et/ou chrysler ce serait environ le
millimes ait fait que ça serait quand
même on
n'est pas dans la bonne
un
militant on peut même pas leurs marques
et souvent très souvent ça se mélange
avec qui la libre et location qui fait
que ya beaucoup de femmes qui dans le
fond et jacques hillairet de cette façon
le sens descendant s'en apercevoir c'est
ce translucide comme liquide et puis je
peux d'aubert mais si ce probablement
peut-être auquel tu penses qui est une
garantie prévoit loeb
après le square thing selon l'auteur
plaisanterie dans les fossés les bonnes
quantités le pitre ça peut aller jusqu'à
500 millions c'est vrai j'ai deux
millilitres
je mettais à doite déshydratée mais tel
est mon métier c'est lui bonne taille
quand même bien en fait que que ayons
d'une crise qui
rappellera dans le fond c'est kiev
pendant mes tons bleutés comme une forme
de pénétration ou non pendant les
activités section des semblerait que la
vessie francs plus quand même rapidement
qui en fait c'est ça le sporting mais
c'est vrai on pourrait douter certains
auteurs qui suggère l'autre sujet parce
que c'est que dans le fond les liquides
à passer au plus fait le con qu'il est
seul y'a pas passer par le processus
complet pour lesquels on doit penser
pour de lui rien n'est fait que ces
expulsés vraiment rapidement c'est pas
mal c'est comme il n'y a pas d'odeur un
fait transparente ces fêtes qui est pour
ceux qui en a qui suggère l'audience
mais en même temps tu es
c'est dommage je trouve pour souligner
dans notre livre que on se questionne
encore sur la validité la composition de
légers culotté d'où ça vient comment
c'est fait et on devrait plutôt célébré
comme est le corps cette possibilité-là
ce pauvre garçon et postures exactement
de quoi c'est qu'on pouvait ou comment
c'est l'important c'est que ce corps le
corps féminin et ses possibilités le
japon devrait quand même d'aider des
femmes des féministes qui vont suggérer
d'appeler le flux de joie
mais absolument c'est pas grave mais
c'est quand même je trouve surprenant
oui quand j'ai encore
tellement de choses on en envoie des
descendants sont infondées solaire mais
on sait pas s'il est acquis quand même
quelque chose qui me surprennent mais
c'est pas mal et les épatants fait pas
mal les recherches qui ferait le plus
plaisir blanc puis il ya ma mis un
certain temps comme il ya un médecin
qu'on avait qu'on avait lu qui suggérait
que les les femmes les personnes qui ont
une vulve ont une prostate oscillerait
prostate féminine mais encore le comme
elle pas la même forme que au niveau du
corps des hommes ou des gens qui ont un
pénis mais c'est ça devient difficile
qu'inquiets pas de références vous êtes
un taux de référence est souvent le
corps masculin ça devient du bout cela
fait classer comme oh c'est pas tout le
monde qui s'entend mais en fait
semblerait il ya même des 10 j'ai vu
comment on appelle mais les
organisations qui développe les
nomenclatures haut niveau c'est plus
physiologique
il ya déjà une organisation dont le nom
m'échappe qui dit qu'on devrait
davantage utilisé le terme de prostate
féminine justement pour parler de
commissaires des glandes par ailleurs et
reason que ça choqué
qu'on puisse avoir une prostate non
seulement prostate c'est moi c'est juste
moi qui ai soeur
way et de vie sexuelle chez les femmes
après comment m'améliorer a tout le
temps
mais après ça pourrait changer la forme
que ça prend la façon dont est
positionné ça pourrait varier d'une
femme à l'autre il ya ceux aussi qui
devient qui devient plus élégamment ne
pas quelque chose de d'assurer on ne
peut pas un mot des algues bleues c'est
plus du sud a expliqué fait qu'elle
était une fois les recherches c'est en
son
nom jacques folly même somme dans les
organes sexuels féminins que dans ceux
de la neige pour les expériences sur
mars c'est pour ça donne ça me parait il
un masque de ah oui
c'est un joli fond mais je viens le
point g lui un qui est faux comme
changer le mode vocabulaire
seulement faut que tu fasses ton
vocabulaire mais fausse huet cesse de
chercher ah oui c'est ça parce
qu'apparemment qu'il y avait une
fascination pour la recherche du point g
le tpiy demain ones autres parce que moi
grande ça c'était comme le mythe c'est
l'eldorado
ouais c'est ça tu veux le chercher c'est
finalement pour les gens qui nous
écoutions pas lui livre qu'est ce qui se
passe avec le point g comment comprendre
le point g c'est en fait le complexe
qu'il tord aux uv trop vaginale puis en
même temps le on va mettre ça au clair
ça n'existe pas un organe un orgasme
vaginal ou kit ordi l'orgasme
immanquablement provient de ton clitoris
peu importe d'où ils portent peu importe
si tu l'oeil par six nations par
pénétration
samim son clitoris mais la première fois
que j'ai entendu parler de son
orgasme vaginal ou clitoridien c'était
un bon
fait une mauvaise éducation sexuelle
taureau il retrouva chine a pressé la
zone que je vous parle et est que
justement on devrait plus de point g qui
ciblent pas le terme dirige mais c'est
dans le fond oui une partie le premier
tiers du vagin qui est plus sensible à
cause de ce qu'on disait tantôt les kits
aux riffs qui chevauchent dans le fond
le vagin et puis qui chevauche l'urée
atrophie factice complexe nautique
littoraux une rétro vaginale parce que
l'élection d'attention très loin du
répit le vagin et on dit même que l'urée
at on devrait le considérer comme un
organe sexuel justement ces faits que
par le plus de point g pied
effectivement
excuse moi de l'interruption mais
mettons comment est ce que
dans le quotidien
on en parle on s'entend que maintenant
dans la dans l'action c'est mon iphone
commencé a trébuché sur le complexe
mais parle de guitaristes et si tu dois
tout super naître peu importe avec avec
quoi ta partenaire
devant lui justesse que ce tour c'est ce
que ça prend du plaisir le temps que
j'ai dit
pendant ton cul nîmes est
ouest et c'est quand même importante et
peut-être pas d'en parler pendant mes os
pour un tel aviv la communication c'est
là qu'est pour une fille plus jeune
excuses métier je me souviens on
entendait il déconne mettons les figures
moi je suis qui te riediennes moi je
suis vaginale sussex peaufinons ça vient
ça beaucoup été populaire v comme une b
par freud
c'est pour les réseaux d or les fameux
parent ou un des pères de la danse font
de la psychanalyse est lui ce qui
faisait autrefois puis c'est resté dans
notre imaginaire que de radier autre
dans les rapports oui oui et bien
fertile qu'est ce que lui freud ainsi
que mais les femmes qui stimulent leur
qui t'arrive qui ont du plaisir par le
guitariste et immature il faudrait
qu'ils investissent leur vagin pour
avoir du plaisir par leur vagin avec
principalement le coït avec un pénis
fait qu'il fallait délaissé donc ces
parties de l'ôter l'organe leur garçon
qui lors des régionales puis les
premiers à voir déconstruit s et
virginia johnson puis williams aux
webmasters qui ont beaucoup analysé
l'aspect puis on en parle de 6e qui a la
réponse sexuelle vous eu dans le fond
ils ont mis de l'avant qui est notée
comme guernesey ya pas de type de regard
sera en fait sous peu stimulé
différentes parties du corps ça peut
être ma blonde peu ça peut être quand
d'ordre pourrait même être dans le font
connaître un orgasme vivent un organe
mais en fait c'est plutôt la stimulation
qui serait externe ou internet
j'espère que
moi habitons la pénétration en général
malgré son chemin confortable ça peut
même être douloureux je préfère m'en
tenir à une stimulation de la vulve et
du bilan de mon clitoris alors que
peut-être que
mon ami vaut elle préférait justement
par la pénétration sans faille apporté
des sensations plus complexes elle a
besoin d'une d'une stimulation plus plus
directe côté c'est juste une question
préférant spi peut importer préférence
tout est valide
les il reste on s'en fout mais c'est ça
puisque c'est précisément pour sûr que
c'est important en fait c'est là que
vient prendre l'importance de la
masturbation le de comprendre sur 2
capable de l'exprimer après 6 vient le
temps ou de jamais l'exprimer ça arrive
jamais mais de pouvoir l'exprimer puis
de savoir exactement c'est quoi toi on
parlait plutôt de
beaucoup de premières expériences
sexuelles de femmes qui essaient avec un
partenaire de saint-pie dur de la swing
party wiimote en main mais c'est dur
d'imaginer
que cette expérience le plus est
positive ou deux c'est vraiment agréable
ici on est passé seize ans je te pose
sexologue mais non
c'est même complexe pour nous de
découvrir
mais pas pour tout le monde pas pour
toutes les femmes la main c'est quand
même plus complexe pour nous d'atteindre
le plaisir de découvrir ce qu'on aime tu
imagines pour vous autres qui avait pas
de wulf de venger et de clitoris tu sais
ce que c'est robbie se soucie un aspect
du livre parce que oui c'est super
féministe mais d'un autre côté je pense
que c'est aussi la responsabilité des
femmes des jeunes filles aussi de
prendre en main leur plaisir parce que
je trouve ça un peu
sts c'est de mettre beaucoup de pression
sur son sa partenaire de dire allez vous
voilà je suis là fais moi jouer si toi
même c'est pas de faire jouer ce comics
pas à l'autre des pistes le
ccre aux chances à mettre la pression ça
met de la pression de
d'amener l'auto plaisir aussi saisi par
rhj en fac je pense que c'est vraiment
trop tes responsabilités il ya quelque
chose si ça doit être extrêmement m
moi je serai soulagé être un homme fait
qu'une femme disent hey
je vois me gérer on va jouer à deux et
quatre fois pas je me connais bien ça va
bien aller pour la langue hausse des
performances là ça fait du bien
putté vous avez souligné que ben ça
devient difficile d'exprimer des
préférences des limites des besoins
qu'un titre connaît pas de provoquer
blair puis aussi malheureusement
beaucoup de femmes et des jeunes filles
qui ont des complexes par rapport à leur
programme jean commenté on manque de
représentation d'hiver les organes
génitaux féminins puis au il ya un super
projet qui le dit nos diversités project
qui soulevait qui à peu près 90% les
femmes qui ont déjà eu des complexes
soient principalement l'adolescence au
début de l'âge adulte par rapport à leur
vulve avec ça devient difficile aussi de
quand on parlait de qu'est ce qui fait
qu'un malaise un inconfort face à la
masturbation ben oui l éducation il ya
toutes les patries arcueil mais il ya
aussi des fois c'est un confort le
manque de représentation le fait de
connaître sa veuve mais d'abord de
nourrir des complexes et si j'ai de la
difficulté à explorer à regarder ma wulf
c'est fait ça devrait être la bonne
c'est imparable de nommer certaines
parties est en mesure de toucher
d'explorer de regarder si ça devrait
commencer par ce complexe qui
renforcement par la pornographie
blanchi
mais
avec quoi
mais dans le fond il y avait des hauts
faits en classe de prendre un miroir de
l'âme et acteurs de ce squat et vers le
sud de regarder le miroir de s'explorer
de prendre le temps de regarder ces
quality puis j'imagine que beaucoup de
monde mais que beaucoup donc c'est pas
la maturité qui font sur un tir cadré
jaune justement en parlant des
diversités de vul vous avez une bonne
section dans les voies ce qui vous
recensez cette étude là je pense que
comme si charge 69
j'ai retenu le chien
méchant à l'école le chef le plus facile
au monde
c'est sûr j'allais pas
j'avais jamais
moi je me souvenais jamais du fautif de
nombre de pam déploie deux nuls qu'on
avait le sens mais si je n'oublierai
c'est comme ça que j'ai passé mes
copains trouver des
c convient béchard
mais mes vraies victimes d'un pied avec
le projet aussi de l'artiste visuel dont
j'oublie le nom là qui a pris des photos
oui des différents marchés pour se
parfaire des illustrations plus simples
et l'importance des hôtes et blanc oui
puisque ce projet là c'est super
pertinent dans le fond le dis parce
qu'après c'est l'illustration tu le vois
dans le livre vous avez vous avez une
page ses acquis et non il ya quand même
des bonnes différence le we be sont
toutes belles sont toutes parts la bulle
est ce que ça te fait jouer est ce que
tu penses que vous plaisir est ce que tu
peux donner la vie au travers de ce taux
elle remplit toutes les fonctions high
five est apte à wulf sérieusement puis
comme si tu disais bon madame messier
avait suggéré de mettre le miroir mais
c'est encore un exercice qui suggérait
ouais ouais c'est sûr mais en fait c'est
comme si je sentais que ça fait
tellement de chansons bringueurs pour
une zone facile de
sinon un autre à face je viens de pensée
en disant ma foi vous dit dans le livre
c'est que même ou parce qu'on parle du
vocabulaire l'importance vocabulaire
puis que même pour celles âgées du vagin
mais je voulais dire vulve mais le
nombre de termes qu'on a pour parler de
tennis le définissent le ballet en gros
c'est un combat pour parler de tout ça
est infini
infinie mais le nombre la technologie et
dont ça a tellement été quel âge et
quand je dis wulf plus j'ai envie de
rire un petit quelque chose du genre
liszt et se poser les bons termes qui
c'est vrai que quand il y ait un
tellement de mots qu'on peut utiliser
pour le pénis la masturbation avec un
pénis mois t on c'est dommage parce
qu'on remarque
les expressions ou ce qu'on utilise les
organes génitaux des femmes c'est
souvent péjorative et negar c'est opter
qui a conduit quelqu'un de quelqu'un
c'est une pause et une poussée
sénégalais péjoratif les indous bague
c'est un terme que les gens utilisent
parfois sous une douche vaginale comme
une indication négative au niveau des
organes génitaux féminins
c'est le mot comme en anglais
et un bouquet tout
comme un vulgaire que fuck you can après
quoi le tpiy ses références exactes un
fossé féminine sexy oui c'est en fait
c'est les hommes évidemment qu'ils se
sont mis à utiliser le sectionner pour
insulter d'autres hommes t'imagines
amanda loin à la misogynie est bien bien
ancrée depuis aujourd'hui on ne sait
même plus on connaît plus les origines
de ces mineurs dont on les utilise avec
une certaine insouciance mais vu peu il
ya quelque chose qui reste aujourd'hui
il va falloir vraiment way déconstruit
les construit weppes et non non ce
travail-là de déconstruction et quand
même
faramineux qui dans les vous parlez de
du mot pénétration de comment ils
utilisent leur pénétration pour pau m ca
du point de vue de l'homme thing puis
après c'est le mot gellusseau puis quand
vous êtes arrivé à ça il fera beau
changer le mot pour circuits ions suisse
et j'ai circuit wct circuit je mangeais
arrêter le fait ok attend que
kevin faut que tu comprennes qu'est ce
qu'on attendrait de conte et entendait
parler dans le fond il sait comme
mettons
catch prentice le sepa
sepa l'attend prends toi le t6 toi qui
prends la table c'est donc nous on parle
de pénétration il m'a pénétré pee wee
dans le fond aussi l' inverse le circuit
aurait pas eu un mot pour ça donc oui
après une relation sexuelle ou jetés
cirque lui et se moquer électrique je
veux juste dire j'ai constitué
mon ami l'autre jour puis alors pendant
la circulation interdite elle apparaît
furent plus mes doigts ouais et de
sécurité tout spécial que lui bon
n'importe quel objet dans le vent que
dexter dont on n'entend jamais c'est que
c'est encore le sait un code mais c'est
tellement un gros code que je comprends
ta réaction je comprends que chacun
pense que c'était proche à garder
jusqu'à mende c'est par ces quelques
pages à new york oui on est vers ce port
voilà là c'est comme pour redonner tout
ça rééquilibre le pouvons la femme ait
jamais dans l'action on est tout le
temps celle qui est prise alors que tu
rends jamais six mois - en réalité en
réalité c'est toi qui prends parce que
les deux qui
force
les féministes que
les profilers
[Rires]
je venais je parlais les enfants une
grimace
faure m inquiète avait pour une fois que
c'est pas les féministes n'est pas
finie et les parfums break mais c'est
juste c'est aussi toute l'espèce de jeux
de pouvoir qu'il faut qu'il faut
vraiment essayer justement d'abattre
encore une fois parce que c'est ce qui
est pas simple puis malgré bien des
raisons où on pourrait vouloir se venger
de la gente masculine
c'est pas ce qu'il faut faire maintenant
c'est sûr il faut pas aller dans l'autre
extrême faut vraiment juste essayer de
trouver un équilibre où les droits de
tout le monde sont respectés dans le
fond puis que tout le monde a la même
valentin porte son genre son identité de
genre c'est vraiment là dessus qu'on
qu'on se bat aussi le fait de justement
pouvoir avoir un verbe
de pouvoir être dans l'action au jeu
c'est c'est vraiment symbolique un peu
pareil résumé symbolique très fort qui
est importante et moi je connaissais pas
le mot
le verbe circulent
à l'effet nocif bref je connaissais pas
en avant et ça fait une couple d'années
que je suis consciente et
très féministe mais jamais je les
baisers jeu les soirées puis avec une
certaine violence parce que aussi on a
très peur qu'une femme base ou four mais
c'est parce qu'elles savent comme dire
qu'une femme fait ça juste pour le sexe
c'est mal vu que ce encore très très peu
accepté alors qu'une femme peut très
bien baisés faire l'amour fourré
porte juste pour du sexe pour entrer du
plaisir sexuel et c'est valable alors
maintenant circuit long mais dans ce
petit circuit on allait perdre parce que
c'est pour cette fusion les termes ces
baignades à mauzac je sais pas s'il sait
bien lui qui a proposé une féministe qui
a proposé ce mot là parce que nous si on
le met en valeur on explique l'origine
deux dans le livre mais ce pas nous
autres qui a inventé les nombreux tirs
et je voulais juste les nommés puis nous
a fort justement dans cette
avec ce mot là c'est que c'est pas
justement quelque chose de complexe pi2
ultra scientifique c'est même moins
compliquée que le mot paix n'était pas
celle employée way qui est juste pour
rebondir ce que tu dis est une fille qui
dit jeu les baisers dans notre
conception tellement tordu
d'aider des sexes pide des en fait du
genre c'est tellement une feuille qui
dit ça mais ton est
considéré comme masculine ou comme la
latium de gamme étant le tips kenzo
notre arrivée des fois qu'ils avaient
une fille mais tant qu'il soit dans le
groupe c'est comme annoncer l on en est
quand même à ce qu l'insee s'ajoutent
des codes qui sont finalement le manque
oui absolument seppi moi je me suis fait
des amis dont la mort dit à des gars
toujours par plaisir un peu de chaleur
ouais un clic et est pas contente j'ai
dit que j'étais content d avoir sauté la
veille on voulait pas sur la il voulait
pas ça a été comme un privilège qui
voulaient garder encore des
pistes et pas nécessairement des cités
zéro dégâts et machiste et misogyne mais
fêteront actuellement dans l'exacte qui
est qui date que
ça tu as l'impression qu'on t'enlève une
partie ton identité quand c'est plus toi
qui pénètre baïse l'on savait jouer
encore ce que je pense des décotes de
masculinité toxique seulement voilà
c'est comme c'est comme si dans la
relation sexuelle il y avait
un gagnant permet de terminer
c'est comme si jeune tout comme étant
moi que je me remets et à l'époque à
d'autres ou est ce que j'ai et et puis
je te prends pas le seul complètement
absorbé par la sexualité maison la tête
qui pis est testé chez paulus et tester
la seule chose à laquelle je pensais le
spi
on est tellement curieux on veut savoir
ce que ça fait c'est un moment où est ce
que je pense là c'est vraiment les
filles au 6 mars que moi de mon
expérience mettons les petits gate et
brand plus excité puis vraiment en plus
comme vueling à la sexualité comme étant
les petites filles à ce moment le haut
puis à ce qu'on les encourage à ça parce
que c'est accepter pour un garçon pour
une fille c'est tellement réprimer et
une cela est une [ __ ] ceux des
relations sexuelles aussi ça si c'est
une grosse houle ireland manière tout le
monde de jouer leur fille dès qu'on perd
autant que les gars ce pas une valeur
tout le concept de virginité c'est de la
grosse marque ça n'existe pas ça n'a pas
de valeur
est vierge si je dis il ya peu tout seul
tout ça c'est tellement mauvais la
louge l'avenir c'est comme à cette
époque là c'est comme si mettons quand
finalement gauche avec une fille qui
avait comme réussi quelque chose de
mécanique est chose tpiy avec le temps
tu es en vieillissant ce rapport lui
disparaît un peu oui moins présent mais
l'impression qu'il reste où tu as un
petit quelque chose de ceux qui comme
facebook ou aux quelque chose parce que
c'est toi tu dis le nombre de personnes
avec qui te coucher moi je suis l'homme
de personne
toi tu vas y fais moi je vais être jugée
sur sa ne devrait pas arriver il s'est
encore comme ça peu importe notre âge
absolument oui mais
non mais non mais non mais je comprends
que de ton point de vue c'est comme si à
l'époque le steak si maintenant - mais
pas vraiment pas maintenant - une
société triste mais non plus que les
cuisiniers encore le concept de
white material versus est un bon coup
dans l'histoire parce que ton bon coup
d'oeil strop koussa pourrait pas être
broyé maintien maintenant ouais
mais vous avez vous sera pas le matin
avec
des gammes étant qui lui je me verrai en
couple avec mais lui clairement je suis
une nuit avec à cause de la quantité de
partenaires sexuels ou de l'avenant à
l'aise avec sa sexualité non toi juste
le fait que propose comme ça ça serait
ridicule mais pour 1 go c'est naturel de
gym femmes selon ses conquêtes sexuelles
selon la façon dont elle affiche sa
sexualité
absolument je connais des gars qui
s'autoproclament suis pas féministe tout
mais que sera-t-il alors blond de la
fille fréquente avec un petit peu trop
c'est trop partenaires c'est comme ça
les refroidit par
qui prend
[Musique]
jamais son travail
mettant juste la déconstruction de ces
codes le
même tu m'aime moi envers moi même c'est
comme ça c'est un travail long blanc
c'est parce que ces réflexions la con
con comporte en j avais aussi le tgv ou
secondaire
thinking l'appui j'en ai eu des high
five l'acaju quand j'ai eu une première
c'est jusqu'à moi j'aimerais ça m'a
rappelé ma fille non mais c'est sa exact
exact c'est exactement ça sauf que cette
vision localement est tellement
ancrée
[Musique]
travail ce que tu parlais de l'éducation
tantôt cl c'est la meilleure chose parce
que mettons
rendu à notre âge faut quand même que tu
décides activement de faire le
changement fils yann qui décident de pol
pot qui pensent juste pas ils vont vivre
toute leur vie sans lui sans avoir ces
changements d'heure puis à faire c'est
que si tu t'en rends même pas compte
ouais c'était pas de prise de conscience
est bête du monde qui vont pas
activement à les acheter votre livre
dont le titre bondit c'est qu'ils
traînaient et sur malte c'est ça
malheureusement mais
travaillons sur la nouvelle génération
secondaire j'ai repensé à 6 tours le pis
j'en reviens pas que ça ce soir heavy
metal mettez à manier avec des rumeurs
qui avait une fille qui n'a aucune
relation anale mettons avec un beauty
tout le monde inc tout le monde savait
mais j'ai envie de mourir
de me rappeler sur le fil du tournoi
mais santé juste et comme c'était la
rumeur qui courait qui émettront tel
capital fille avait une relation anale
mais on parlait juste de la fille elle
la fête de l'âne alpina n'empile c'était
comme si puis en y repensant d'un os
encore lisse mais 2 2 pourquoi parler
juste de la finance pourquoi vraiment
parler d'histoire
pourquoi qu'on parlait juste de la fille
qui a comparé d'être ceux comme si c'est
elle qui était dans le tort qu'ils
savent pas
mais c'est bon c'est cool réalisée juste
sur l'os est parfait il ya tellement de
choses qui est il tellement de choses
que quand qu'on ne réalise et je pense
les deux dés puis mettons les 15
dernières années maintenant le 30 le
type au secondaire c'était les droits
des dernières même été depuis ce temps
nous mettons pitié avec tes mouvements
sociaux mitigé que lui piteux clé puis
on s'est mis à parler plus les lie même
les séries à télé ont comme adapté
vraiment là leur contenu puis andré
qu'est ce qu'on voit mettez des années
2000 à l'époque contre secondaire les
films on parle des mecs aiment pas et
plutôt pitié jusque là c'était comme
normal et accepté de les grossman idc
connu le savoir écouter ce fax t c'est
totalement normal que vous ayez
participer à des discussions à jaming
jeune fille la danse et
je dis je pense pas qu'aucune féministe
portes de jugement là dessus parce que
tout d'abord tu es un enfant en stage la
facture le top présenter une vision de
la vie comme quoi ça c'est bien c'est
mal dit conformes à ceux naturellement
c'est normal l'importance le c'est juste
le cheminement qu'on fait à partir du
moment où on accède et nouvelles
informations qu'on ait le courage de
faire comme au qu'est ce ça me
déstabilise peut-être surtout ce que je
sais sur toute ma vision mais je vais
quand même être ouvert à veux penser
puis à avoir un regard critique par
rapport à ma vision de la vie tcc ceux
qui bouffent de raisons mais aussi j'ai
l'impression que ça bouge ça bouge
paillettes mais faut c'est ben oui
encore et si nulle part lors du colloque
c'est moi j'ai l'impression jusque dans
les dernières années j'ai donné des
conférences à mettons en milieu et c'est
comme scolaire bons établissements
d'enseignement supérieur d'autres de
milieu je le vois c'est j'ai
l'impression qu'elle est question sont
différentes les apports des étudiants
n'utilisent étudiantes sont différentes
pitt et moi je vous ce super stimulant
mais je vois une différence entre les
générations préfèrent mexique ne
serait-ce que le consentement c'était
pas le montrer très populaire le yo
c'est un
logement non plus à l'adolescence jamais
on n'a jamais parlé de consentement et
pourtant mon chez moi c'était super voir
le nous et parler à sexualité ce mais
c'était comme je pense qu'on prenait
pour acquis que salek consentants puis
il y avait aussi quelque chose d'aussi
[Musique]
ttc comme un peu la responsabilité de la
femme de satisfaire son homme le t on en
cinq sets fait garder ton somme ce n'est
pas qu'ils aillent voir ailleurs
avec les consentements ce n'est pas très
très à la mode ces quantités normales ou
se dire mettons bien pourquoi qui est
allé chez lui d'abord 6 à 8 ans et plus
afin d'amasser 10 comme déculpabiliser
oui pis si ce matin j'en ai eu qu une
craque tu te faisais taper ses doigts
par tes parents en arrivant à l'école
mais 6 et foule au pied mais
malheureusement on entend encore moins
au travail auprès des marées sur une
vingtaine des survivantes de violence
car trafic seule fois que j'entends des
choses parfois très choquant mais si je
pense que avec toutes les sommant les
vague de dénonciations les réseaux
sociaux et à une communication qui est
différente c'est les gens prennent la
parole s'il ya eu quelques années dans
une école secondaire ray mais jeudi à
quelques années mais je pense que c'est
l'année passée où il ya deux ans déjà
renseignements le port du vêtement ces
genres et comme là je pourrai là la
fille et les pantalons pour de ligue 1
c'est fait qu'il ya de plus en plus de
jeunes qui soulèvent ces ou deux mois je
me sais aussi que j'ai vu des groupes un
moment donné de sixt est soulevée par ce
qui est venu jeunes feuilles qu'on
voyait un peu sa brassière à travers ses
vêtements où elle avait prononcé elle
avait pas porter de bracelet
personnes et puis il y avait demandé la
direction il y avait demandé de
retourner à la maison à cause de serre
étaient justement les jeunes s'est
soulevée dès corrigeant samedi dans les
couloirs dans tes comme dans leur
établissement scolaire pour dénoncer ces
affectés je pense que de plus en plus
les gens sous l'ère voulait qu'un
quelque chose qui considèrent qu'ils
stigmatisent enquis auprès fin vois pas
ce que la reprenant l'histoire
c'est de l'exemple que tu délègues
secondaire s'il y avait un rugueux
nangang est faite elle gagne 6,4 ce que
vous faites on aurait fait ferme ta
gueule et on arrête et on aurait
continué j'ai eu mon métier le cam se
répéta c'est le temps que la nageuse qui
s'étaient trop la majorité mais là
maintenant je vais pression que dans la
même situation se basent quelqu'un fait
comme un ado est ce que c'est exagéré
mais on fait quand même cette raison si
après il va peut-être plus un mouvement
qui suivrait le trio qu'il forme à ce
moment le tube qui radient genre on s'en
serait qu'ils n'avaient pas les mêmes
modèles
américains
gens réalisent que
michel explorer ça s'est su que sa
sexualité avec une flûte non c'est comme
si la pire affaire le difficile à faire
kiffer le kiki si le moteur narratif du
film c'est qu'ils apprennent qu'une
femme comme
déduire une flûte à bec si le feeling
croiser avec owen wilson aussi qu'à
manille apprend que charles a fait le
tri pour qu'un intérêt et comme vierge
ouais c'est comme si ce
contrat c'est comme l'argent la
présidence
oui parce que mes
pommettes vingt mille vierges
les gens viennent sur lui parce que ça a
été le point de départ l'induction de te
regarde aussi il y avait beaucoup de
films pierre n'a encore le qui était
sexiste et les femmes dans cette storl
ont même pas d'interaction entre réel et
en a qu'on connaît à peine leurs noms
sont là que pour servir les hommes c'est
le genre le but l'histoire c'est que les
gars veulent coucher des faits avant la
fin de l'année c'est ça leur objectif
que les filles ont aucun mot à dire sur
cette source il ya un nom pour comme
l'espèce de tests de brigil béziers
loubet ciel mais oui pour leurs intérêts
ce niveau justement de sexisme d'un film
c est ce que les personnages ne sait pas
exactement toutes les questions mais
c'est entre autres est ce que je pensais
être que plus que trois personnages
féminins qu'elles pèseront les
interactions prendrait elle est ce que
les interactions parle d'autre chose que
de leur rapport à rawdon bref c'est même
très intéressant de l'appliquer à des
dessins animés pour enfants mais parce
qu'on se rend compte qu'on apprend très
vite aux petites filles c'est quoi leur
place qui on apprend très vite aux
garçons aussi des codes de
leur principe le prince charmant c'est
trop
oui
est ce que ça vous arrive antilles on ne
parlait aussi de dim et on sait
maintenant il ya des séries justement
maintenance excédés qui gêne je trouve
qu'ils vraiment bonne c'est qu'ils m'ont
un peu la sexualité d'une curée à liszt
mettons le tpiy mais ce que ça vous
arrive encore d'être chaud qui mettons
par dessoudé proposant des médias ou des
représentations dans
quotidiennement mois d'été sont
des exemples oui
j'ai
voulu aux attentes lire le piéton
s'est pas pressé
[Rires]
non du coup diplomatique n'a filtré sur
toutes les problématiques encore le le
concept de virginité très excitante que
les hits le fait que le go soit multi
millionnaire qui lui fasse tout
découvrir de la vie écoute c'est
si difficile de trouver quelque chose de
moins
dégradant condescendant envers les
femmes elle qui n'a yves qui tombe
éperdument amoureuse super romantique et
il y a il l'a fait jouer alors qu'elle
n'avait jamais connu l'orgasme tout cela
sérieusement le sais j'y ai pas cru ce
qui est triste c'est que écoute il ya eu
un lectorat féminin monstres et c'est
les femmes qui tripent sur les films et
les livres et qui a pensé impatiente je
me dis oh la la il ya il faut vraiment
aussi est ce que justement les jeunes
filles parce que parce que tu ne peux
pas idolâtrer ce genre de relation la
malsaine le seco climat toxique loge de
6,6 et non si problématique toute la
ligne je me disais on peut pas non plus
culpabiliser les femmes qui aiment
leur perspective que l'on nous a appris
très jeune que mais premièrement mais
souvent l'hétérosexualité sur un
piédestal coupe sur un piédestal
lamater heureusement il est tantôt c'est
que cette question c'est comment savoir
plus de représentation des diversités
passé comme ça me donnait en une option
principale puis il ya des options qui
sont meilleurs que d'autres soucis dans
les avions c'est l'hétérosexualité ça en
fait partie on donne aussi l'impression
d'un film d'un ferry je parle beaucoup
pour ma génération le mais c'est que les
femmes doivent s'attendre à des petites
nièces et comme ben dhaou cette femme le
batave se dit même si c'est mal fait
devraient le prendre qu'un cas ce que
bien cette personne de toit ou c'est
justement trouver le lieu comme un
rapport où justement comme
financièrement et seuil il lui fait
vivre des choses et you je m'en sacre
était un jet et un truc
qui se comment ça se fait qu'on ne le
port l'a fait à la main à la pâte
réveille pas et que les femmes soient
excités par ce mois c'est pas si je juge
pas les femmes sont excités c'est juste
que ça me fait peur parce que c'est
malsain
c'est non pas parce qu'il ya eu autant
de fans soit attiré par un rapport de
domination dans le fameux oui ça me
dérange pas là que je vais te mettre une
laisse ça te fait plaisir et même où il
n'y a pas de stress mais dans la vie de
tous les jours je veux construire à pied
d'égalité hollis qui t'excite pas grave
si sam ça me dérange pas mais le sais
que c'est pas juste au lit le rapport de
forces est dégueulasse tendance à
préciser ma meilleure note dans
tellement d'autres
mais là que c'est la construction
sociale va tellement loin ça va jusqu'à
jouer avec ce qu'on pense qu'on veut
c'est pour l'élection qui comme ses
baskets aux femmes d'avoir des enfants
le de vouloir d'être désiré être mère à
quel point c'est plus normal de pas qui
il ya encore du jugement envers ces
femmes - qui veulent pas d'enfant c'est
un peu de sens le couple en tant que tel
le fait que dans une relation amoureuse
ou sexuelle
quotidien monde wild 2 qui décide et
sûrs pourquoi je peux pas être avec toi
immature de confier nous re la jalousie
pourquoi tout devrait être rentable en
axe moi je couche avec tous dans le fond
on a tout dit cependant semble que je
vous aime construit tout bien tout se
fait pas de sens tout ça c'est de la
construction sociale et
foireuse à mon avis ouais j'avais juste
titre sur j'ai un jeune ami qui est
vraiment voir par rapport à tout seul et
il lui bisexuels pays dans un couple
woerth et puis
il me parlait de
lui qu'un que ya du sexe anal quand lui
fait fait de la sexualité analyse ça m'a
jamais
intéressé
puis m'a juste dit souleymane diop c'est
parce que tu manques puis il passa une
opération qui me restait à cette crise
c'est peut-être
moi je me suis jamais questionné par ce
qui est construction sociale c'était
comme bello se poursuit donc pas pour
ses moyens de faire se tient en fond tu
fais avant audrey sinon oui exactement
mais où était en fait et c'est ya des
trucs que tu as aimé
non mais
on verra leur bien sur le calendrier
tendon
on essaie ce qui était un thème ce que
tempo t'aurais pas d'actifs pour juste
perte nette de barrières
tant que c'est qu'on sent pas évidemment
est en train thur ça revient encore est
ce qu on dit qu'on est très canet dans
des rôles c'est un homme et pénétrant
une femme est bien être et une femme
peut pas être pénétrante l'homme
hétérosexuels ouais un geste d'attention
jusqu'à comment sûrement là vocabulaire
ça va être déjà un bon produit
exact où j'avais une amie qui disait un
gloubi soit englobé m'attends à ce
que dans le fond tu le fais enrobé c'est
accepter le vagin en cercle en robe
enfilée c'est vraiment ça
est ce que ça donne le oui
c'est clairement réconfortant
mais c'est fou ce chamakh a manqué de
langage conditionne notre rapport à la
réalité la c8 le travail juste le fait
que la langue française soit comme tu es
une des premières choses qu'on nous
apprend primaires c'est comme le
masculin l'emporté sur le féminin mais
ce qui comme une phrase qu aucune
institution
absolue masculin la part du pouvoir 1 go
94 fille ces masques votre livre est
écrit au féminin justement
en premier lieu oui je trouve que c'est
moi le tournant en velay cohérents par
mois puis vous êtes stoll c'est le lev
est super inclusif le tire vraiment
vraiment à chaque fois que si jamais les
femmes toujours les femmes ou personnes
avec une bulle c'est un
métier dans un livre comme cela pour
faciliter la compréhension et tout
commençait à ali allait avec les achats
cmo m masculin point e point e s le tir
pour tout le temps c'est de faire un
langage accusé ça devient quasiment
insoutenable
c'est en termes de lecture tandis que
l'heure de choisir de faire puis moi
dans le fossé vas-y au féminin et j'en
ai rien à crisser le joie de lire ça va
être aussi 5 pour moi dans la lecture
que de prendre un langage inclusif qui
finit plus le truc les épisodes ça a été
dur parce qu'il est féministe on nous
dit tout d'abord je n'avais pas envie on
s'en est parlé tantôt on a plutôt invité
justement de tout féminisé parce que on
voulait pas servi la même médecine qu'on
avait stephen brun c'est important que
ça soit comme les deux sexes mais là la
force et qu'est ce que tu veux que ce
soit facile à l'essai que ce soit le
social il ya quand même aussi
décomplexée ce type si la lecture
devient un enjeu supplémentaire à la
compréhension sa tenue complète y ont le
sait tu veux que ça soit accessible ce
soit avec le plus de monde puisse les
pieds on l'avait envisagé il ya
plusieurs façons d'utiliser t à
différents types d'écriture en cuisine
l'autre maman pour différentes raisons
en italie vers ce type le mais j'étais
contente que tu soulignes sont vraiment
eu la sensibilité on essaie le plus
possible que tout le monde puisse se
sentir concerné ou que des passages les
comprime faudrait parce qu'en fait tu
sais on a vraiment essayé d'être
inclusive parce que c'est important que
c'est beau c'est l'éthique et de la
masturbation féminine mais en fait qu'
on précise très tôt dans le livre c'est
important pour nous que
peu importe l'identité de genre si la
personne a une vulve puycalvel à
stimuler mais il ya des pistes pourrait
l'attendre go for it s'adresse à toi
excuser ou même site pas de vulves mais
kuyt terme et on peut en apprendre plus
et que ces sources il ya des bouées
section c'est sûr que nous on est deux
femmes sigean sadek ont été assignés
femme à la naissance puis quand on se
considère femmes c'est sûr que tu es
c'est notre réalité fait que c'est sûr
que c'est ça peut limiter certaines
informations mais on ainsi le plus
possible d'être inclusive à différents
niveaux dans les c'est très bien fait
que on invite les gens qui nous ont
écoutés
se procurer votre lit oui il est
disponible partout
cauwet renaud bray archambault buropro
station votre libraire du coin sur les
bancs déserts mais on perd tout ce que
les encourageons à eux seuls expliquer
si jamais on va vous suivre vous un peu
plus gai
ouest à g roxane oiseaux salut ça me
fait plaisir de voir une si belle place
mais ce nom ses autres outils n'ont
conquis de vous le voir galerie t quand
on parlait de l'art des représentations
diversifiée des vul et
illustratrice
de l'avoir trouvée pour ouvrir leur quel
artiste incroyable et la suivent miss
wilcox sur instagram c'est hallucinant
son travail très cool merci beaucoup
du contenu excellent tu as tout un
podcast combien
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le pétrole entre le pitch vous
abonner pour trop dollars par mois sans
trop de longs mois et trois pièces par
mois hors glace par mois et vous avez
les pas de carte en avance acquise avec
les premiers de votre groupe d'amis
avoir quitté les podcasts qu'ils
allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une avance
quand vous à l'étude de la dynamique
entre les amys tout le temps avons une
avance sur les jobs en avance les entre
deux toits mais avec pétillante une
avance sur l'humanité complète en plus
en plus parce que le chèque le podcast
unis voulu nous entendre jean zay
davantage on fait des encore moins de
filtres à préchac podcasts etc là on
vient de finir de tourner le podcast on
vend jaser on va t'il et nicole non
nicolas hulot maintenant et ayant comme
un fils travaille la place travot des
pas à tailler le mets en jason par la
conversion qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce
si vous voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous c'est exclusif
sur pécule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous